There are friends who are very well meaning
but who nevertheless have a habit
of responding in unfortunate ways
when we reveal a trouble to them.
They try with considerable vigour to cheer us up.
We may appreciate their underlying good nature,
while nevertheless profoundly resenting their particular technique.
For what we may want from them above all
is not a swift enjoinder that our problems are in fact, despite appearances, easily solvable
but rather a shared moment of sadness and mournful sympathy.
There are times when we can't believe in quick answers
but we want company nevertheless.
We want to give way to a low-level muted sadness
and a joint acceptance that life is inherently difficult.
Sadness isn't always a disorder that needs to be cured.
And yet, the dominant tone of many friendships
continues to be cheerful or, its more brittle cousin, cheery.
A good mood that tolerates no other.
This falsely presumes
that the best way to please others
must always be to impose a vibrant frame of mind
when, in fact, admission of despair is a key tool in the process of friendship properly reimagined.
In a discussion of parenting styles
the psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott
once identified a particularly problematic kind of child carer -
the person who wants to "jolly" babies and small children along,
always picking them up with exaggerated cheer,
bouncing them up and down, and pulling wide funny faces,
perhaps shouting "Peekaboo!" repeatedly.
This criticism might feel disconcerting.
What could be so wrong with wanting to keep a child jolly?!
Yet Winnicott was worried by what effect this would have on a child.
The weight was subtly not giving the child any chance to acknowledge its own sadness-
or more broadly, its own feelings.
The jollier doesn't give the child an opportunity to set the tone.
He or she just wants to impose a mood which may have no basis in the child's reality.
The jollier doesn't only want the child to be happy-
more alarmingly, it can't tolerate the idea
that it might be sad.
So unexplored and potentially overwhelming
are their own feelings of unresolved disappointment and grief.
Childhood is necessarily full of sadness...
As adulthood must be too, insisted Winnicott.
Which means we must perpetually be granted
the possibility of periods of mourning -
for a broken toy,
the grey sky on a Sunday afternoon,
or perhaps the lingering sadness we can see in our parents' eyes.
The friend, no less than the carer
needs to remember
how much of life deserves to have solemn and mournful moments-
And of how much loyalty
we will always be ready to offer those
who don't feel aggressively compelled
to deny our melancholy.